[Music]
a 24 on your Friday morning what's cool
at school well sometimes when you do
learn the lessons of History it's even
more fun to go ahead and repeat them
especially when you're the fourth grade
class at Green Valley Christian School
in Henderson and you're creating the
imaginary town of Greenville after nine
weeks of intensive study of the real
Colonial Williamsburg from blacksmithing
to basket weaving from chopping carrots
and celery to making wigs and playing
checkers they learned how to chop and
saw wood and how to tell all of their
stories in a big show that took over the
school's worship area
filling their brains with information
and putting smiles on their faces
yeah each student had to make a
scrapbook of their character writing
samples clothing examples maps that had
to be true to those historical times so
congrats to the Green Valley Christian
fourth graders their families and the
school for keeping history alive you
know we always want to know what's cool
at school you got something let us know
cool at school on the community tab of
our website or email cool at school at
8newsnow.com
wow that was a lot of work oh my
goodness there are even more pictures of
all the stuff that they were doing and
the presentation was just about a week
ago and the parents super proud of the
kids the kids proud of themselves they
they're smiling pretending they're like
Paul Revere or whatever